>> My name is Nabil Elshourbagy, and I am
from [INAUDIBLE] Biomedical, a biotechnology
company based in Philadelphia, and basically
it's
involved in drug discoveries using the biotechnology
as [INAUDIBLE].
I think role model is an important aspect
in the Middle East, and one
of the countries that I studied and have admiration
for is Qatar. And
they have invested quite a bit of money in
the recent years in bringing
the gap between the Middle East and also -- and
the United States and
Europe by bringing collaboration over from
-- from -- by bringing
collaboration from Europe and United States
back to the Middle East.
This kind of cooperation should be expanded
greatly and I would
recommend strongly that we have more and more
investment in this type
of collaboration.
So that we can lift the big gap between the
Middle East and this
country.
And this could be done because we have two
things bringing and the
manpower which will bring both of those to
the Middle East.
And apparently, I am from the Middle East,
I'm from Egypt, and we have
a lot of scientists in the Middle East and
in the United States and
Europe that other chief a great deal so we
have that capability.
Thank you.